all right it's time for this week's pet
project amy lee joins us from nspca and
she brought along someone who needs a
safe and caring home hey amy
hi how are you i'm good i'm good i'm
ready to meet gambino
onto today he's the mastiff boxer i'm
hearing
he is he's really a gentle giant this
guy is gambino he
is a seven-year-old boy and he's what
can i say this guy is a love bug he's
super
mellow he just burped excuse you um he's
very very sweet and he would be
the perfect addition to any home i mean
he's a great great dog
um you know we'd love to find him you
know a loving home especially in time
for the holidays because he really
deserves it
definitely we'll call him the big
gambino how's that
i love it
what is the best home for him he is a
large dog
he's a large dog but as you can see he's
a really mellow dog um you know
obviously
you know we want to provide him with
enough you know sufficient
exercise he does get along with most
dogs we always say if you have a current
dog to bring them in just to make sure
that there's a meet and greet happening
oh
hi uh meet and greet happening to make
sure that they get along but he does
like to horse play with other dogs you
know
probably a larger size dog he's about 90
pounds 94 pounds
um you know this guy's a snuggler um so
you need to have a big
couch i mean that's probably the most
important thing um but just a loving
home and
and you know a family that that would
really really uh welcome him and make
him a part of that family
definitely he i know he's big but he
looks like a cuddler
he looks like killer i mean you know a
little bit of drool little slobber
uh well amy how can we adopt a pet from
you guys during this time
absolutely so what you do is you're
gonna just check out our website you're
going to go to the adoptable dogs page
there's a little tab on there you can
book an appointment
and you just schedule an appointment to
come in and see us wear your masks and
um and meet gambino all right thank you
so much amy thank you gambino
if you're interested in adopting a pet
go to nevada nevadaspca.org
or just call them at 702-873-7722
we'll be right back